bonjour antoine on continue cette
présentation de votre travail sur l'
enquête sur les gilet jaune blessés à
vie pendant les manifestations
vous avez rencontré un prénommé david
qui a été touché à l'oeil par un tir de
l bd en mars 2010neuf quelle justice
manifestants at il reçu pour le moment
oui bonjour alors david bernstein il a
41 ans comme vous le disiez la russie un
tueur au visage
c'était au moment où le fouquet's était
en train de brûler sur les
champs-elysées à paris le 16 mars 2019
il cherchait justement à sortir de la
zone de violences au moment où il a été
impacté aujourd'hui il vit avec une
grande colère en lui ni pelle reprendre
pied après avoir perdu l usage de 7 à
gauche et comprend pas que l'igpn n'ai
pas trouvé le tireur du mbd 40 qui
l'impact au visage alors que le
procureur qui a pris la charge du
dossier lui l'a trouvé en seulement
trois mois donc il a porté plainte
contre le tireur qui en fait une tireuse
et policières nationales et contre le
préfet de police de l'époque qui était
michel delpech
à présent il attend impatiemment un
procès et un jugement comme on va les
écouter ce qu'on veut qu'ils nous
procurent à et lui valut la truite sur
en même pas un an
il ya quoi tron 2 mois deux mois commun
dans sa vie alors que jp n'a rien trouvé
quand on veut on peut
alors antoine comment david bridoux mme
stein est il reprit sa vie la vie de
david comme je vous disais extrêmement
dur aujourd'hui parce que tout d'abord
pour exercer son métier avec sa blessure
et découpe des pièces métalliques dans
le secteur aéronautique
c'est très difficile et surtout parce
qu'il est traumatisée psychologiquement
il souffre au quotidien die des traits
noirs suicidaire et vous pourrez
retrouver l'intégralité de ses propos
est et de ce qu'ils avaient à nous dire
sur dans notre article notre enquête et
bien sûr sur la vidéo intégrale qui
passera sur nos réseaux sociaux et on va
suivre cela évidemment sur arte france
point tv merci beaucoup
pour cette enquête dernier épisode à
suivre donc demain merci antoine